- Speaking of stories
there was one- did she tell you the one
about the red dress?
- She did not.
- What red dress?
- There was a photo shoot
and all the girls showed up wearing red.
- I don't re-
- It was awesome.
- Maybe sounds
- I'm sure you don't remember it
- Vaguely familiar but I don't really know
- It was amazing it was like World War III
that the blow black lasted
for about two weeks on set.
- Oh yeah it sounds vaguely familiar.
- What are you wearing?
(gasps)
- Oh my god.
- You said you were gonna wear blue.
- You said you were wearing
green so I thought it was safe.
- I'm sick of green.
You said you were gonna wear blue.
- I'm sick of blue!
- Cue the popcorn.
(cheer and applause)
(laughter)
- Please welcome Brian
Austin Green, everybody.
(cheer and applause)
(saxophone plays)
(mumbled)
- Woo!
Okay.
- Did you say it's been almost
thirty years in the intro?
- No! Twenty.
- What did I-
- (Brian) You said thirty.
- Did I?
- (Brian) You did. Yeah.
- Yeah
- Okay, I'm going to
- Yeah she did.
- redo through that later.
- Well no don't redo it.
(laughs)
- 'Cause it has been almost thirty years
since the show started but-
- (Kelly) Oh, really?
- But that made me feel terrible.
- (Kelly) Oh my god!
(laughs)
That was like, yeah this last month,
this past month they were like,
seventeen years ago you won Idol
and I was like
- That's great.
- Yeah.
Okay let's not talk about that.
- Thank you for aging me.
- Right.
- Actually though, age is better.
My life has exponentially improved
- Oh it's so much better
- Since I turned thirty.
- Yeah
(Cheer and applause)
I was saying to somebody backstage
'cause they were talking about their
mid-thirties were the best
and I was saying like I at the mid-thirty
people start taking you seriously
- Yeah
- and they respect you a
- little more
And it's different
it's a different point in your life
- Yes!
- And now I'm 46 and everybody takes me
way too seriously.
- Yeah
(laughter)
No but you're funny
that's what I love about-
and here's actually the best part
so you're Instagram handle is
@arent_you_that_guy (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah
(laughter)
- Which makes me love you-
(laughs) 'cause that's funny.
- (laughs) Thanks.
So what happens,
who do they always mistake you for?
- Well so I came up with
'Aren't you that guy'
because literally everybody goes
"Wait aren't you that guy?"
(laughter)
and so I was like
Oh it's perfect!
- (Kelly) Oh!
- (Brian) And I'm not big on social media
'cause it's a whole different way
of like marketing and promoting things
- Yeah.
- and I just don't
- Mm.
- I don't play that way
Like I- Lala, one of the women
who I worked with on 90210
she has almost 9 million followers
on Instagram
- Wow!
- And I have like 300,000
(laughs)
- I love it.
- (Brian) And half of them
of them are like
they follow me because of my wife
and then
(laughs)
and she always gives
me a hard time because
she wears bathing suits
and does all these like
you know really good shots
- Wow
- (Brian) And then I have pictures of like
the ocean or benches or trees
(endearment from the audience)
and she's like-
- (Kelly) Oh
- This is why you don't
have as many followers
as I do.
(laughter)
- 'Cause you're a true photographer.
- Yeah.
- They don't get you.
(laughter)
- So back to your story
so I had a woman in Vegas,
which you were talking about
- Mm-hmm.
- Chase me through one of the casinos
into an elevator
and she was like out of breath
and she was like "Oh my-
- Wow.
- Can I take a picture with you?
It's like of course you can, sure.
So I took a picture with her
I was like this is really flattering.
She was like "Thank you
so much Mr. Timberlake".
(uproarious laughter and gasps)
Yeah. Yeah.
- At that point do you
just leave it and go
"You're welcome"?
- No! Yeah, totally!
- No!
- I said "Oh sure, no problem!"
And the doors closed
I never said anything to her.
(laughter and applause)
- Let's talk about the reboot
the 90210 reboot
- All right.
- Because this show
was enormous
- It was
- (Kelly) Like back in the day
You could not escape it.
- Yeah
Thirty years ago, thank you.
- Yeah, no but it was
it was before-
(laughter and cheer)
- It was-
- Hey there it is!
- And it was before even like
the Friends like you know
Friends got-
- Yeah
- This was Friends back in the day
- This was that kind of huge
- Yeah
how fun is it to kind
of get back and work-
- It's-
- in that zone?
- It's surreal, you know,
we've had to do like photo shoots
and stuff for Fox and to be
sort of recreating these
what they call 'Iconic Pictures'
is crazy.
It's crazy A. To think that
I'm in an iconic picture
'cause that just makes no sense
to my brain at all.
(laughter)
- That's like every time
people talk about Idol
and they're like it was groundbreaking
and I'm like "Sure".
- Right.
- You feel weird when its you.
- Yeah, thanks.
- Yeah.
- With a question mark, yeah.
- What are you supposed to do?
- Right, exactly.
- You're welcome.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- I just wake up every day and try-
like what are you supposed to say?
You feel like a tool either way, yeah.
Anyway I love you-
(laughter)
No but
- Thanks Idol.
- Yeah I do, actually-
I don't but-
Okay so my producers this is what-
I like to track down
some awesome things that
maybe people don't know
okay Brian and so we
tracked down this album.
- Fantastic.
- Tracked down this album.
- Oh yeah, where?
- Can we get a zoom in on that?
(cheer and applause)
(laughter)
- Where did you track that down?
- We have a team
- 'Cause that's- yeah
- Of people
- You had to investigate
for that.
- (Kelly) Wait, wait
Do you still rap?
- (Brian) I don't.
- You don't?!
- No because I'm 46 and I would hurt
- Which is even better
- But I would hurt myself if I did.
- No.
- People always ask me to rap or dance
and that's-
- Were you saying you
want to dance right now?
- No
(laughs)
(cheer and applause)
- I was kidding.
(Holiday music)
Wait. Do you hear that?
Do you know what this means people?
It's ambush Christmas!
(cheer)
- It's just snowing where the cameras are?
- So, no
(laughs)
we have a very small budget
so there's literally people up there
in the rafters just making it snow.
(laughter)
'Cause were not Oprah y'all.
- That are like shaking bags-
- Yeah they're shaking bags!
- I'm covering our waters
- Yeah, well
- Just 'cause I don't
want you to choke on-
- Well Brian,
y'all Christmas is my favorite holiday
no joke
(cheer and applause)
and since this is my-
it's my show, okay
so we're gonna celebrate Christmas
every month of the year.
(laughs)
That's what we're doing.
(cheer and applause)
But it's always going to be
an ambush.
Nobody's ever gonna know when it's coming
so to kick off this month's-
(laughs) Yes!
(laughter)
to kick off this month's celebration
I have a little gift for everyone, okay?
(cheer and applause)
We have a karaoke
machine- thank you, Chris,
thank you.
We have a karaoke machine in every one
of our green rooms, okay?
And I start each show with Kelly-oke so
we thought only appropriate
that everyone in the audience is going
home with a Pop-Up Oke All-In-One
Wireless Karaoke Microphone.
(cheer and applause)